welcome to the world of Agriculture
where every animal has a unique and
essential role in sustaining Life as we
know it in today's video we're diving
deep into the top 10 most important farm
animals and uncovering the vital
contributions they make to our lives
let's get
started number one chickens chickens are
the backbone of poultry farming and a
vital source of food worldwide they
provide protein packed eggs with hens
capable of laying nearly 300 eggs
annually their meat whether Broiler
chickens raised for consumption or
freerange breeds is a staple in
countless Cuisines Beyond food chickens
help farmers by eating pests and weeds
naturally improving soil Health through
their
droppings number two cows cows are the
Giants of the farm supplying milk that
turns into essential dairy products like
cheese butter and yogurt dairy cows like
Holstein and jerseys are prized for
their High milk yield while beef cattle
like Angus and herfords contribute to
Global meat production in many rural
areas cows are also used for plowing
fields and transporting goods making
them indispensable for both sustenance
and
[Music]
labor number three pigs pigs are
efficient converters of feed into meat
making them a primary source of pork
bacon and ham their High reproduction
rate ensures a steady supply for Farmers
but pigs contribute more than just meat
their manure is rich in nutrients often
used as organic fertilizer additionally
pigs are known for their ability to
consume agricultural byproducts reducing
food waste on farms
number four sheep sheep provide three
major products wool meat and milk wool
from breeds like Marino is used to make
warm durable clothing sheep meat
particularly lamb and mutton is a staple
in many Cuisines around the globe
sheep's milk though less common than
cow's milk is a rich base for specialty
cheeses like Feta and rokford in some
areas they even play a role
acting as natural
lawnmowers number five goats goats are
highly versatile animals goats milk is a
popular alternative to cow's milk due to
its digestibility and nutritional value
often turned into gourmet cheeses like
chevra their meat is a delicacy in many
parts of the world particularly in
developing regions goats are also known
for for producing valuable fibers like
Kashmir and mohare their ability to
thrive in harsh environments makes them
a Lifeline for farmers in arid
[Music]
regions number six ducks ducks are
multi-purpose animals valued for their
meat eggs and Feathers duck eggs are
larger and richer in flavor compared to
chicken eggs making them a delicacy in
many cultures their meat is tender and
often featured in high-end dishes Ducks
also contribute to Pest Control feeding
on insects and weeds while adding
natural fertilizer to the
[Music]
soil number seven horses horses have
been Humanity's trusted partners for
centuries while Modern Machinery has
reduc their role in farming they still
play a crucial part in transport plowing
and even tourism breeds like the Belgian
draft horse are known for their
Incredible strength while lighter breeds
are ideal for hering and managing
livestock horses also Foster strong
emotional bonds with humans offering
companionship and therapeutic benefits
number eight turkeys turkeys are iconic
animals particularly in North America
where they are synonymous with
Thanksgiving feasts they are a
significant source of lean protein and
their ability to grow rapidly makes them
efficient meat producers turkeys are
also Hardy birds that can adapt well to
free range farming benefiting both the
environment and the farmers bottom
line number nine honey H bees honeybees
are the unsung heroes of Agriculture
their primary role is pollination which
supports the growth of over 75% of the
world's crops including fruits
vegetables and nuts in addition to
pollination bees produce honey a natural
sweetener packed with health benefits
and Beeswax used in products from
candles to cosmetics without honeybees
food production would drastically
decline
[Music]
number 10 donkeys donkeys are the
ultimate Farm helpers known for their
strength endurance and calm temperament
in many developing regions they are
relied upon for transporting goods
plowing fields and fetching water their
resilience in harsh climates and ability
to subsist on minimal food make them
indispensable for farmers in remote
areas from the industrious honeybee to
the steadfast donkey these animals shape
the foundation of Agriculture and
sustain life around the globe which
animals role surprised you the most let
us know in the comments below and don't
forget to like subscribe and share this
video with fellow animal
enthusiasts thank you for watching and
remember to appreciate the incredible
animals that keep our world thriving see
you next time